Aires mistaken as King Lear Hall header
excellent sir
Charlotte prehistory minidom O'Hara saga
bar for abandon
now I will translate the last four words
of those for you whose native language
is English or Swedish
that's for our dear children and our
grandchildren the 2000 citation 218
citation for economic sciences
highlights the causes and consequences
of technological innovation and climate
change the science of climate change was
founded in 1896 the very year that
Alfred Nobel died and established these
prizes since that time the full
implications of climate change and it's
impacts have been illuminated by the
intensive research of scientists in
different fields from agronomy and
atmospheric sciences all the way to
zoology and these studies depict an
increasingly dire picture of our future
under uncontrolled climate change the
signal contribution of economics is to
recognize that climate change is a
harmful unintended side effect of
economic growth known in the technical
language of economics as an external
effect or an externality economic theory
suggests that the best remedy for such
externalities is a pollution charge a
charge on carbon emissions of what is
now called a carbon tax a carbon tax
raises the price of carbon emissions to
reflect the social costs it also
provides powerful incentives to reduce
emissions and as my fellow laureate Paul
Romer has shown in his studies to
develop new low-carbon technologies so
after more than a century of research in
different fields the science is clear
the economics is clear
and it is now up to those who represent
us our elected leaders to act
responsibly to implement durable and
effective solutions we should not
underestimate the obstacles some are
real such as the need to develop new
technologies or to forge international
agreements and institutions that will
promote cooperation some obstacles are
unnecessary and man-made such as those
posed by the financial interests of
polluters or the ludicrous arguments of
some of our politicians but I end this
toast with words for students for young
people and for our grandchildren
you are likely to live through to the
end of this century the globe at
century's end will be vastly different
from today and the condition of our
world will depend on the steps that we
in this generation take now to slow
global warming I hope that you our
children and grandchildren will look
back in the years ahead with
appreciation I hope that you can say
that we in this generation had the
resolve to take the steps to overcome
the obstacles real and unnecessary to
take the steps necessary to preserve our
unique and beautiful planet so talk and
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]